now by now we've all become pretty
efficient at avoiding dumb things you
know dumb things like hugging people
shaking hands at a time where we just
can't do that non-essential travel six
feet apart grocery store washing our
hands don't touch the gas handle you
know no face touching wiping knobs after
you before you touch them or frankly not
even touching knobs at all our country's
learned a lot we've learned about social
distancing we've learned about the hands
we've learned about staying away at
least during the time that this is even
a little bit around this disease or
whatever you want to call it life in
America is on a pause and an attempt to
stop this virus well we have more than
80 million Americans that's a lot who
are staying home due to state orders now
that's undoubtedly slowing the spread of
this virus which is a very good thing
more than 550 Americans have now succumb
to kovat 19 we don't have a breakdown
yet on median age or whether they had
underlying conditions but we will at
some point and of course we on the
Ingraham angle know every life lost is a
tragedy every life lost is irreplaceable
but we're testing a lot more people it's
a really good thing and we're finding
that more Americans are infected but as
the president noted tonight we're
gathering new data on mortality rights
as well the mortality rates a big thing
for me because I think we're very
substantially under 1% now that's that's
it's still terrible it's still the whole
thing the whole concept of death is
terrible but there's a tremendous
difference between something under 1
percent and 4 or 5 or even 3 percent so
that's something that we're learning now
and I think the number may be lower than
people think because of what I've been
saying now we're now just at the end of
day 8 with 7 days more to go of our
national timeout the president with a
multi-factor analysis rightly raised the
unintended consequences of a prolonged
shutdown can't keep it closed for the
next you know
for years okay this is going away where
we're gonna win the battle but we also
have you know you have tremendous
responsibilities we have jobs we have
people get tremendous anxiety and
depression and you have suicides over
things like this when you have terrible
economies you have death probably and I
mean definitely would be in far greater
numbers than the numbers that we're
talking about with regard to the virus
and of course we all know that along
with the human death toll of the virus
as the president discussed the economic
carnage is mounting one of my old
friends from El Salvador called me today
and she was crying her husband lost his
plumbing job today
her sister lost her marketing job on
Friday we are going to save American
workers and we're going to save them
quickly and we're going to save our
great American companies both small and
large this was a medical problem we are
not going to let it turn into a
long-lasting financial problem of course
some of the press being the simpletons
that they are they want to make this a
struggle between dr. Anthony Fauci of
the CDC and the president if we get to
next week we're deciding or you're
deciding what to do with these
guidelines whether to ease them or
reinstate them for another 15 days will
you follow the advice of dr. Burks and
dr. Falchi if they say you should
maintain them and others yes then
ultimately have to make a decision but I
certainly listen to them I listen to a
number of people but I have a lot of
respect for dr. Fauci and for dr. Burks
and I'll be listening to them and others
that we have that are really doing a
good job now in the end it's the
president who is the one tasked with
making the tough calls that's why he was
elected now in peacetime and in wartime
he has the same responsibilities he gets
a lot of inputs he convenes a lot of
meetings with a lot of smart people and
he looks at the data and the projections
but the final decision always rests with
him
now we all know that in life there are
inherent risks we live with those every
day when we step into our cars when we
frankly we just walk out the front door
it's always a balancing act in life and
in politics between freedom and security
Liberty and safety like the president
the president is never gonna please
everybody never but America at some
point soon he said weeks not months
we'll have to function again we have to
be a country together again and safe
again at times like this we need more
not less input from really smart people
and at times like this think of Priya
wet Iraq war it's difficult to be the
one questioning the consensus phenomenal
scholars like Stanford epidemiologist
John Ian itis or Yale's David Katz
they're taking a beating for even
suggesting that we may need to
reconsider some of our initial thinking
about this virus and our response to it
they should be heard along with everyone
else without censorship the widely
respected Silicon Valley forecaster and
statistician Aaron Ginn has had a
persuasive and well argued piece on hope
and optimism on the virus removed from
the Internet then it was repulsed posted
elsewhere he's being smeared right now
by academics this is wrong and revealing
the American people in the recent
polling and if it's accurate they seem
to appreciate the way the president has
handled this crisis day after day he
stood before the press corps it's not
fun answering questions for hours his
love and his respect for the American
people for our health care professionals
and our businesses our workers is
evident shines through he doesn't want
our solution to this crisis to end up
being worse than the insidious virus
itself that means everyone has to work
together everyone has to do his or her
part I'll work with anybody to help the
American people I will I don't care who
it is I work with anybody if I feel I'm
gonna help
the American people in the American
worker Canada Democrats who've held up
this latest relief slash dem ulis bill
for the last two days can they say the
same or President Trump just said
Schumer and Pelosi have been disgusting
what they've done to American families
and American workers they're holding the
country hostage trying to extract policy
concessions like wind and solar
subsidies and mail-in ballots early
voting for the fall has nothing to do
hero to do with Kovan 19 we had a deal I
was pretty sure we had a deal last night
if you would have told me at a certain
time like about nine o'clock I would
have told you we pretty much have a deal
and then all of a sudden it changed
change fairly rapidly and you know it
was unacceptable have been bad for our
country and they were asking for things
that would have not been good I mean
things that that bore no relationship to
what we're talking about we said that's
not the game we can't play that game now
we can because this isn't a game this is
a country and we're trying to save
people their lives and the process our
freedom our Constitution we're trying to
make hard decisions here with the best
information that we currently have real
data and again the balancing freedom
security Liberty safety but at the end
of it all we still want a country that
is a strong chance of being prosperous
and happy again remember the pursuit of
happiness and that's the angle